bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va pas
des cartes et plus particulièrement des
preuves de l'existence de dieu chez
descartes dans ses méditations
métaphysiques descartes a proposé
plusieurs preuves de l'existence de dieu
ou en tout cas plusieurs arguments en
faveur de son existence puisque par
définition une preuve c'est censé être
probants c'est sensé emporter l'adhésion
intellectuelle or on va voir que ça n'a
pas vraiment été le cas des cartes a été
beaucoup critiquée par ses successeurs y
compris jusqu'à l'époque contemporaine
on citera par exemple le livre de
antonio damasio l'erreur de descartes
dans lequel il montre que des cartes
faisait fausse route sur la question du
dualisme entre le corps et l'esprit
damasio se situe clairement du côté de
spinoza sur cette question à savoir
qu'il défend une position moniste l'idée
que le corps et l'esprit sont en
interaction permanente des cartes a été
énormément critiqué de tous bords
d'ailleurs aussi bien par les partisans
du rationalisme scientifique que par les
défenseurs d'une philosophie chrétienne
les rationalistes reprochant à descartes
sa croyance en dieu et les croyants
reprochant à des cartes son goût
excessif pour la raison donc des cartes
est en même temps l'une des plus grandes
figures de la philosophie française et
l'une des plus critiques et faut dire
que en france la critique c'est un petit
peu notre sport national
c'est très gratifiant pour l'ego la
critique ça permet de se sentir au
dessus de ce qu'on critique mais peu
importe ce n'est pas le sujet de la
vidéo du jour le sujet de la vidéo ça va
être d'analyser les preuves avancées par
des cartes pour démontrer
rationnellement l'existence de dieu
on avait vu dans la vidéo sur pascal que
pour pascal dieu ne peut pas faire
l'objet d'une démonstration rationnelle
car la foi en dieu relève de ce que
pascal appelle les vérités du coeur et
que foi et raison ne communique pas pour
pascal vouloir démontrer rationnellement
l'existence de dieu c'est comme être un
contre sens contre sens sur la nature de
dieu et la nature de notre croyance en
dieu donc ici mon
à utiliser des cartes comme un prétexte
comme une occasion d'approfondir la
question du rapport entre foi et raison
et se demander en quoi la tentative de
descartes de démontrer rationnellement
l'existence de dieu va davantage nous en
apprendre sur les limites de la raison
que sur l'existence de dieu
alors on va commencer par le premier
argument que donne des cartes en faveur
de l'existence de dieu c'est celui de la
présence en l'homme de l'idée d'un fini
des cartes nous dit que l'homme possède
en lui l'idée d'un fini il est capable
de concevoir l'infini il est également
capable de concevoir la perfection or
nous dit des cartes
c'est étonnant c'était étonnant parce
que l'être humain n'est pas lui-même
infinie l'être humain est fille il a des
limites dans le temps naissance et mort
et puis l'être humain il se caractérise
aussi par son désir le fait de désirer
ce dont ils manquent donc à chaque fois
qu'on désire on exprime notre manque si
nous étions infinie nous n'éprouvons
rions pas de manque donc nous
n'éprouvons rions pas de désir donc
l'être humain est finie l'être humain
est un parfait et pourtant il est
capable de se représenter un être
infinie est parfait pour des cartes
il est tout à fait étrange que l'homme
possède en lui le concept d'un fini car
alors ça voudrait dire qu'un être fini
pourrait être à l'origine du concept
d'infini et ça pour des cartes
ça mérite qu'on s'interroge comment se
fait-il que l'homme possède l'idée de
quelque chose qui n'est pas en lui
naturellement et donc ça pour des cartes
ça constitue la preuve que dieu existe
alors vous allez me dire quel est le
rapport bien le rapport c'est que pour
des cartes
cette idée d'un fini étant donné
qu'elles n'émanent pas de l'homme
lui-même il faut nécessairement qu'elle
ait été placée en lui par un être
lui-même infinie autrement dit c'est
dieu qui a placé en l'homme
l'idée d'un fini donc vous comprenez
l'argument c'est de dire que je ne peux
pas être l'auteur d'une idée qui ex
ed ma nature je ne peux pas être
l'auteur d'un concept qui ne fait pas
partie de mon essence le concept
d'infini ne peut pas avoir pour origine
un être fille
c'est donc un être infinie qui en est à
l'origine
c'est donc dieu donc ça c'est le premier
argument avancé par des cartes en faveur
de l'existence de dieu vous remarqué que
cet argument se présente comme un
argument rationnel et quand je dis qu'il
se présente comme un argument rationnel
je veux dire par là qu'il y à une
tentative de la part de descartes de
recourir à une démonstration rationnelle
c'est à dire que des cartes ne va pas
appuyer son raisonnement sur la notion
de révélations il ne va pas tenter de
démontrer l'existence de dieu par la
seule expérience de dieu il va tenter de
proposer une démonstration
c'est en ce sens que cet argument se
présente comme rationnel il se veut le
fruit d'une déduction logique quasiment
mathématiques et pourtant cet argument
ne fonctionne pas alors pourquoi est-ce
qu'ils ne fonctionnent pas bien pour
plusieurs raisons la première raison qui
est surtout d'ordre terminologique c'est
le fait que le concept même d'infini est
issu du concept deux fini infinie
ça veut dire qui n'est pas fini
autrement dit on définit l'infini à
partir du fini par référence au fini et
en faisant ça et bien quelque part on
montre notre incapacité à envisager
l'infini de manière positive
on montre qu'on n'est pas capable de
concevoir l'infini autrement que comme
la négation du finit donc ce n'est pas
un infini réel c'est à l'infini
artificiel c'est un infini reconstruit
par l'esprit humain donc ça c'est la
première chose la deuxième chose c'est
que le concept d'un fini peut très bien
avoir une origine empirique
autrement dit il peut très bien être
issu de l'observation
non pas que l'infini soient présents
autour de nous
non pas qu'il existe dans la nature des
choses ou des espaces infinis
mais simplement lorsque vous voyez
quelque chose qui s'étend à perte de vue
du point de vue de la perception humaine
c'est un infini
si vous êtes perdus au beau milieu de
l'océan
vous avez un contact avec l'infini un
infini visuel mais un infini malgré tout
quelque chose qui s'étend sans limite
autour de vous même chose si vous êtes
en plein milieu du désert du sahara
vous allez voir le sable s'étendre à
perte de vue et donc sur le plan
empirique
vous êtes face à un infini vous êtes
face à quelque chose qui n'a pas de
limites
donc on peut très bien avoir on peut
très bien se représenter
la notion d'infini à partir de notre
expérience sensorielle
c'est paradoxal mais ce n'est pas
incompatible
une troisième objection qu'on peut faire
au raisonnement des cartes c'est qu'il y
a
d'autres concepts que nous possédons qui
loge dans notre esprit et qui ne
correspondent pas à des choses qui
existent dans notre monde on peut faire
un raisonnement par l'absurde c'est à
dire que le concept de néant concept de
néant il n'est pas non plus le fruit
notre expérience parce que le rien
intégral le rien absolue bas quelque
chose dont on peut faire l'expérience
d'ailleurs là encore vous remarquerez
que le mot néant étymologiquement il est
basé sur une négation néant la négation
de ce qui est donc si on voulait être un
petit peu méchant avec des cartes on lui
dirait qu'il existe un dieu du néant
parce que le néant n'existant pas dans
la nature il faut forcément que ce soit
le nez en lui même qui est placé cette
idée dans notre esprit donc l'argument
des cartes se retourne contre lui donc
ici on s'aperçoit que la première preuve
de l'existence de dieu chez descartes
elle se heurte à des contradictions
logique et c'est d'autant plus
intéressant de le souligner que la
démarche de descartes encore une fois se
voulait rationnelle elle se voulait en
conformité avec les règles du
raisonnement logique parce qu'on a pu
voir dans la première vidéo sur des
cartes des cartes est quelqu'un qui veut
fonder la vérité sur des bases
rationnelles
d'ailleurs les cartes fait partie du
mouvement rationaliste c'est à dire
qu'ils estiment que la raison doit être
placée au dessus de tout et c'est parce
qu'il estimait qu'il n'y avait pas de
contradiction entre la raison et
l'existence de dieu qu'il a cru pouvoir
s'appuyer sur la raison pour démontrer
cette existence
dieu parce qu'il faut bien comprendre
que si des cartes nous avait dit que
l'existence de dieu n'était pas
démontrable et biel auraient fait l'aveu
des limites de la raison
comment défendre la raison tout en
admettant par ailleurs que la raison est
impuissant dans certaines situations
comment promouvoir l'investigation
rationnelle de la vérité si c'est pour
dire ensuite qu'il y a des choses qui
excède la raison qui dépasse la raison
donc des cartes été pris en tenaille
entre son exigence rationaliste et sa
croyance en dieu dont il n'a pas vu que
la raison ne suffisait pas à la
justifier
de ce point de vue là on peut dire que
pascal était beaucoup plus cohérent en
établissant une séparation entre le
domaine de la foi et le domaine de la
raison bien pascal se mettaient à l'abri
de ce genre d'objection donc maintenant
qu'on a identifié les principaux points
faibles de ce premier argument en faveur
de l'existence de dieu
passons au deuxième le deuxième argument
en faveur de l'existence de dieu sait ce
qu'on a appelé l'argument ontologique
alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire
arguments ontologique bien l'ontologie
celle études de lettres et l'argument
ontologique
c'est l'argument qui va s'appuyer sur
l'être de dieu autrement dit sur sa
définition on va déduire l'existence de
dieu à partir de la définition de dieu
donc là ça peut vous paraître un petit
peu abstrait dont qu'en est-il
concrètement la concrètement des cartes
nous dit que dieu par définition est un
être parfait et infini ça c'était déjà
cas dans le premier argument
ok supposons est donc bien si dieu est
un être parfait
ça signifie qu'il possède toutes les
qualités il possède toutes les qualités
rien lui fait défaut et donc si rien ne
lui fait défaut bien on doit arriver à
la conclusion que l'inexistence serait
un défaut or si dieu possède tous les
attributs
il doit posséder l'existence un être
parfait et infini ne peut pas être
envisagé comme inexistant il ne peut pas
envisager comme manquant d'une qualité
et donc si dieu ne possède pas
l'existence dieu ne peut pas être dieu
c'est logiquement intenable conclusion
dieu existe nécessairement alors là vous
serez peut-être dit que cet argument est
étrange parce que on est passé de la
définition d'un concept
le concept dieu à la preuve supposée de
son existence
autrement dit mme on est passé d'un plan
purement conceptuel à un plan
existentiel
c'est à dire aux plans d'une existence
réelle c'est bien ce qui s'est passé
dans cette démonstration on est passé du
plan abstrait au plan concret on est
passé d'une définition théorique à une
conclusion pratique mais pourtant si
vous analysez l'argument de manière
purement rationnel purement logique et
vous allez voir que l'argument est
cohérent est ce que veut dire par là
c'est que ce que 10 d'écart qui n'est
pas absurde c'est pas illogique c'est
pas illogique mais ça ne marche pas
alors les réfutations
cet argument par les successeurs de
descartes ont été extrêmement nombreuses
donc ici on va simplement se contenter
d'évoquer la réfutation de la part de
quand emmanuel kant qui je le précise
était lui-même croyants et donc il
n'avait aucun intérêt à dénigrer la
tentative de démontrer l'existence de
dieu quand c'était pas un militant athée
mais c'est quelqu'un qui disent
haussiers radicalement l'ordre de la
raison et l'ordre de la foi ou en tout
cas qui avaient compris les limites de
la raison qui avait compris que la
raison ne pouvaient pas accéder à
certaines réalités
c'est quelqu'un qui estimait que au delà
de la réalité sensible
il y avait un ordre de réalité
supérieure qui ne nous était pas
accessible qui n'étaient pas accessibles
à notre entendement il appelait ça le
nous mène la chose en soi et c'est
d'ailleurs le fil conducteur de toute
l'oeuvre de quant à savoir de définir et
de délimiter les pouvoirs de la raison
et comprendre les pouvoirs de la raison
selon quand c'est surtout comprendre
l'impuissance de la raison donc quand tu
n'avais aucun intérêt à réfuter une
démonstration de l'existence de dieu
mais simplement par honnêteté
intellectuelle
il se refusait d'accorder du crédit à
une démonstration qui selon lui n'en
était pas une
hessel nous le démontre de manière très
simple voilà ce qu'il nous dit il nous
dit que si on postule que dieu est un
être parfait
ça veut dire qu'on postule qu'il possède
toutes les qualités on est d'accord
si on définit dieu par sa perfection
bien ça veut dire qu'on inclut dans la
définition le fait que dieu existe
comprenez si vous dites que dieu est un
être parfait et vous dites en même temps
que l'existence est un élément cette
perfection ça veut dire que vous avez
définies dieu comme un être existants
c'est ce qu'on appelle un argument
tautologique un argument tautologique
c'est un argument qui prétend démontrer
ce qu'ils présupposent c'est comme si je
vous disais la méchanceté est une
caractéristique de la nature humaine
donc les humains sont méchants mais mon
donc ma conclusion elle n'est pas une
conclusion puisque ce que je dis dans ma
conclusion c'est ce que je pressens
supposée dans ma première phrase c'est
ce que je
supposé dans la prémisse de mon
raisonnement je pars du principe que les
êtres humains sont méchants pour en
déduire que les êtres humains sont
méchants mais ça ça marche pas c'est pas
une démonstration
c'est une pétition de principe c'est une
affirmation qui repose sur elle même
donc définir dieu par sa perfection pour
ensuite nous dire que l'existence fait
partie de la perfection pour quand
c'est le signe d'une démonstration qui
n'en est pas une on ne peut pas
démontrer l'existence de dieu par sa
définition
voilà donc ça c'est la réfutation de
l'argument aux logiques par contre qui
ne s'arrête pas là hein parce que
effectivement il reste ce problème du
passage d'un plan à un autre du plan
conceptuel au plan réel et comme le dit
quand dans sa réfutation
ce n'est pas parce que vous avez la
représentation d'argent dans votre poche
que vous avez de l'argent dans votre
poche
et ça je pense qu'on est tous bien placé
pour le savoir voilà donc on en arrive
au terme des deux arguments énoncés par
des cartes en faveur de l'existence de
dieu et au terme de cette analyse
eh bien on s'aperçoit que la tentative
de descartes a été pour le moins
infructueuse elle a été d'autant plus
infructueuses qu'elle prétendait
s'établir sur la raison et donc si on
voulait être un petit peu sarcastique
avec des cartes on pourrait dire que
descartes a eu trop foi en la raison il
a cru que l'efficacité du modèle de
démonstration mathématique site
s'appliquait à tous s'appliquent est
nécessairement également à dieu et c'est
là où descartes à peut-être provoqué
malgré lui le contraire de ce qu'il
escomptait
en effet en voulant réconcilier la foi
et la raison des cartes a finalement
opéré le divorce entre la foi et la
raison en voulant conforter la fois par
la raison des cartes a démontré une
chose c'est l'inconscient habilité entre
la foi et la raison parce que si la
raison doit venir au secours de la fois
et bien ça veut dire que la foi ne
parvient plus à se justifier elle même
quand il écrivait que dieu est mort
évidemment qu'il ne faisait pas de dieu
un être mortels il veut simplement dire
que la croyance en dieu était morte
parce que la croyance en dieu
été supplanté par la raison et notamment
par la raison technique
l'être humain a besoin d'idoles il se
construit ses idoles et ses idoles sont
à l'image de ceux qui leur assure de ce
qui satisfait son intérêt lorsque les
hommes n'ont plus besoin de dieu ils
peuvent s'en débarrasser ils peuvent
adoré une nouvelle idole et la raison
peut très bien être une nouvelle idole
tout ce qui peut être porteur d'espoir
va être porteur de fois et c'est pour ça
qu'on peut dire que pas plus que la foi
ne se démontre elle ne se discute car ce
qui pour nous est porteur d'espoir
ce dans quoi nous plaçons notre foi nous
est propre
[Musique]
dieu n'est peut-être que la réponse est
question mal posée au fond peut-être que
dieu existe pour ceux qui y croient
peut-être que dieu existe comme existe
le soleil c'est à dire pour ceux qui le
voient pour ceux qui
ont exposé à sa lumière parce que la
même façon que le soleil n'existe pas
pour ceux qui vivent enchaîné dans la
caverne peut-être dieu n'existe-t-il pas
dans le coeur de ceux qui n'ont pas foi
en lui
ce n'est pas
ce que nous avons des raisons de croire
que nous croyons c'est parce que nous
croyons que nous trouvons des raisons de
croire je vous remercie
[Musique]